SPEAKER 1: More effective
than drones or thermal optics,
a group known as the black
mambas were recently awarded
as the champions of the Earth.
They protect wildlife from
dangerous poachers within one
of Africa's largest game
reserves, Kruger National Park.
The group doesn't use any
weapons and they're all women.
They say it's hard for a
woman to do that kind of job.
That's a man's job, so
because I was happy about it,
I proved them wrong.
CRAIG SPENCER: Our
attitude is to make
this the most undesirable
and unprofitable and most
uncomfortable place to poach.
To the members will take them
quickly and chase and put
what we call a
disruptive [INAUDIBLE]
so that the poachers
run away and just don't
get close to the rhinos.
SPEAKER 1: The Black
Mambas were created
after the reserve lost 19
rhinos in a period of only
a few months.
AMY CLARK: The Black
Mamba anti-poaching unit
was first founded in 2013.
Snaring dropped 97% in the
first year, in this region.
their first 13
months of operation,
we didn't lose a single
rhino throughout the reserve.
Still even till today in
2016, it has dropped by 56%.
SPEAKER 1: Craig
Spencer was in favor
of a model that did not entirely
rely on weapons or violence.
CRAIG SPENCER: It's a bit like
the British policing model
with the bobbies on the beat.
We need the people that walk
the beat every single day,
so they develop this sort
of institutional memory,
I call it.
Everybody must know them.
People must feel comfortable
to approach them and give them
information, ask them
questions about things.
Women are, in my opinion,
much better at that.
Because they observe.
AMY CLARK: So we've
got the rangers that
are the boots on the ground.
LEITAH MKHABELA:
We're also listening
when we're doing first patrol.
If we can hear anything
suspicious or related
to the poachers and the
vehicles outside the reserve
that are walking
on the main roads.
When we do sweeping, we are
looking for snares and tracks
and poacher's cams.
We are following
fresh tracks that
leads us to fresh snares
that can kill any animal.
AMY CLARK: So if
they find a problem,
they'll report it on the
radio to the operations room.
And they'll take the
next step further.
Either to call in an armed unit
or just notify the supervisors.
SPEAKER 1: New members
of the Black Mambas
begin with four weeks
of intensive training
on arrest procedures,
sporting tracks,
searching vehicles, and more.
AMY CLARK: During
that four weeks,
they'll also spend
a week learning
how to act if they walk into a
lion or a walk into an elephant
and what to do to
keep themselves safe.
And then at the end
of that four weeks,
they do a two-week
paramilitary course.
LEITAH MKHABELA: The
training very much hard.
Do you trust yourself?
Are you patient?
Are you strong?
Do you want to empower women?
SPEAKER 2: Faster, faster.
SPEAKER 3: Let's go, let's go!
SPEAKER 1: And that was one
of the motivations for Leitah
to become a Black Mamba.
As a patrolling officer
for the past two years,
she believes that their
success is reshaping roles
for women in communities
where job opportunities can
be limited.
AMY CLARK: All the Mamba's are
between the ages of 20 and 30
and then they're all from the
local communities and villages
surrounding the
Balule Nature Reserve.
The majority of them when,
when they first arrived,
were very shy and didn't
really speak out much.
After the time that
they've spent with us
and doing the job,
their confidence levels
have absolutely skyrocketed.
LEITAH MKHABELA:
This job teaches me
how to take care of money,
how to behave when you are
a woman working for yourself.
It makes me grow up.
In a lot of ways,
this job changed me.
SPEAKER 1: One of the
fundamental goals of the Black
Mambas program is more
than just protecting.
It's also about educating
and changing the community's
attitude about wildlife.
Lewyn Maefala is the Black
Mamba's education officer
who works with the
nearby communities.
LEWYN MAEFALA: We bring
in the Black Mambas
into the classroom, whereby they
teach the learners about what
they do in the field.
They don't know of that role
of animals in the environment.
They don't know animals
boost our economy.
What they know is those
animals, all of them
are there to kill them.
And for me, it allows me to
say no, it's not like that.
They have a very important job.
And we need you guys to help
us to save these animals.
CRAIG SPENCER: The Greater
Kruger National Park
is three million
hectares in total.
This is our unique treasure.
This is our Louvre.
People from around the world
been visiting it for 160 years.
We don't want to lose that.
We want the people on
the boundaries of here
to feel that as well.
LEWYN MAEFALA:
There was one child,
the one who was just
here, [? Nahnahl, ?] she
was the one who said in front of
everyone that, when I grew up,
I want to be like you,
because you teach us
to look after our environment.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: To learn
how a herd of elephants
are protecting rhinos in
Nepal, watch this next episode.
SPEAKER 4: When a
rhino is discovered,
they will communicate.
Then the elephants will move
in, in a circular formation
around the rhino, to keep
it from running away.
SPEAKER 1: Thanks for
watching Seeker Stories.
And be sure to subscribe
for new videos every week.